[Musique]
dans la nuit du 24 février 2022 la
Russie envahit l'Ukraine une opération
qualifiée de spécial par le Kremlin
contre l'ancienne république soviétique
[Musique]
au-delà de l'effroi et de l'effet de
sidération provoqué par cette offensive
le fait que la guerre est de retour en
Europe et cette guerre qui devait être
éclaire s'annonce longue et meurtrière
pour endiguer la propagation du conflit
au-delà des frontières de l'Ukraine dans
les pays membres de l'OTAN la France
renforce sa participation au sein de
l'Alliance Atlantique à l'est de
l'Europe
surtout dans les premières semaines de
déploiement que c'était un moment
historique ou en tout cas très important
la première impression que j'ai c'est de
ressentir toute la gravité de la
situation le retour de la guerre aux
portes de l'Europe c'est un esprit de
solidarité directement qui s'empare de
nous tous cet esprit de solidarité de
l'OTAN tout simplement
alors comment la France a-t-elle réagi
comment assume-t-elle son rôle d'allier
crédible au sein de l'OTAN comment les
armées sont-elles montées au front de la
sécurité européenne et surtout comment
sommes-nous arrivés là à bientôt 8 mois
du conflit immersion dans les coulisses
de notre sécurité collective
après des années de tension entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie l'impensable
s'est produit le 24 février 2022
l'invasion russe provoque une
condamnation massive de la communauté
internationale
sans être en guerre contre la Russie
l'Alliance atlantique riposte
immédiatement sur son flanc oriental en
projetant de la puissance dans ces pays
membres
à ce titre la frange joue pleinement son
rôle et la réponse ne se fait pas
attendre moins de 12 heures après
l'invasion russe ravitailleur et
Chasseur français interviennent dans le
ciel polonais
4 jours après les premiers éléments
français débarquent grâce aux moyens
aériens en Roumanie en une semaine c'est
1700 tonnes de fret qui ont été projetés
au total ils sont 500 militaires
français a composé avec 300 belges le
bataillon fer de lance de la force de
réaction rapide de l'OTAN
et on sent la responsabilité qu'on a en
tant que leader chef de ce bataillon de
démontrer nos capacités d'être prêt
d'être totalement prêt avec nos alliés
pour pour remplir la mission qui nous
est donné si on a des cultures qui
peuvent être différentes on a les mêmes
références donc c'est en fait assez
facile de s'intégrer et de devenir
camarade et on apprend des différents
armements des différents procédures qui
peuvent varier d'un pays à l'autre mais
c'est au final assez facile de
s'intégrer les uns avec les autres et de
travailler ensemble
mais aux premières heures de conflit
cette posture défensive et dissuasive de
l'OTAN aux frontières de l'Ukraine va
plus loin alors engagé au levant au
large de l'Irak dans la lutte
antiterroriste dans le cadre de
l'opération Chamal le groupe aéronaval
français change de cap
le gros père en aval qui était déployé
en Méditerranée donc orientale dans le
cadre d'un soutien direct à l'opération
Chamal en quelques jours a basculé de
mission pour passer de la Méditerranée
orientale en soutien à Chamal à la
Méditerranée centrale pour faire des
missions cette fois-ci de réassurance de
soutien direct à l'OTAN en volant avec
ses chasseurs rafales avec ces 09 OK
dans le ciel de l'OTAN en Roumanie et en
Bulgarie donc il y a plus de 50 missions
de rafales qui ont été conduites et 15
missions de surveillance aérienne de
hockeye et donc tout ça en l'espace de
quelques jours
notre posture ça a été déjà de
contribuer à la défense de l'intérité
territoriale de l'Alliance bien sûr des
intérêts maritimes qui vont avec c'est à
dire les approches maritimes et très
concrètement pour nous ça s'est traduit
par un repositionnement du porte-avion
plus à l'ouest pour déployer nos avions
en mission de défenseurienne ou police
du ciel si on veut au-dessus de la
Roumanie la Bulgarie pour apporter un
éclairage au-delà de l'espace aérien
roumain et bulgare sur la mer Noire
notamment sur les espaces aériens
contiguës et apporter une présence armée
avec la panoplie de d'armement du Rafale
en complément bien sûr des avions de
l'armée de l'air qui eux partaient de
Mont-de-Marsan et de ceux qui étaient
déployés en Estonie les Mirage 2000 qui
était brillant de streaming
le GAN c'est pas que le porte-avion
c'est aussi des frayates et donc les
frégat de Lugan on peut compter à peu
près 5 frégates généralement en groupe
et en aval on compte également un semoir
à nucléaire d'attaque ce dispositif
s'était allé de la Méditerranée centrale
à la Méditerranée orientale pour être
capable non seulement d'occuper l'espace
maritime de montrer que la France et
l'Alliance manœuvre librement malgré la
présence russe et surtout pour être
capable de comprendre la manœuvre des
Russes qui était une manœuvre qui
occupait la manifester la centrale la
mer Égée et l'Amérique Ternat orientale
très rapidement
notamment avec notre allié américain
avec lequel on est pleinement interopéra
bon on a les mêmes brins les mêmes
catapultes on peut envoyer nos avions
sur un porte-avion américain et recevoir
un avion américain à bord ça c'est le
signe quand même d'une proximité
culturelle et interopérabilité
importante mais aussi vrai bien sûr avec
tous nos alliés de l'alliance de l'Union
européenne et dans une situation comme
celle-ci ça nous a permis d'être très
vite efficace militairement
effectivement le message il est fort à
l'égard de nos alliés la France est un
allié crédible est un édifiable qui
déploie ses unités de première ligne
quand c'est nécessaire engage du groupe
et on avale il y a toujours un double
signal évidemment un signal pour nos
compétiteurs puisque ça envoie un signal
défensif dysphasif ça va permettre de
montrer qu'on est capable de mobiliser
dans le temps de manière autonome des
moyens qui peuvent produire des effets
importants mais c'est aussi parler à nos
alliés évidemment puisque selon la
taille la performance la spécificité des
moyens que vous vous apporter dans une
coalition qu'elle soit alliée ou de
circonstances votre voix votre poids
votre crédibilité va changer en
l'occurrence le fait d'impliquer le
groupe Air en aval d'entrée de jeu a
permis de montrer que la France en
complément des forces que les poignées
en Roumanie ou des avions de l'armée de
l'air qui ont volé dans des pays baltes
et en Pologne tenait son rôle d'allier
fiable et crédible
au-delà de son engagement quasi immédiat
en Pologne en Roumanie et en
Méditerranée la France participe
également avec ses alliés otaniens et
européens à des missions de police du
ciel en Bulgarie poursuit ses exercices
austaniens de grande ampleur en Norvège
et prolonge sa présence en Estonie et ce
tout au long de la frontière est de
l'OTAN le but afficher une posture de
fermeté vis-à-vis de la Russie
alors comment en sommes-nous arrivés là
le 7 août 2008 Billy lance une offensive
militaire contre l'une de ses provinces
l'eau City du Sud tout comme l'apasie
les deux territoires prorus veulent
faire sécession
Moscou intervient et écrase les troupes
géorgiennes qui seront forcés de battre
en retraite la Russie entreprendre des
actions agressives sur la scène
intentionnelle depuis plusieurs années
on se souvient de la guerre Russo
giorgienne en 2008 on se souvient
l'année de la Crimée de la
déstabilisation du Dombas tout cela
s'inscrit dans une logique historique
l'État russe déjà à l'époque soviétique
affichait une certaine agressivité et la
Russie poutinienne n'a pas rompu avec
cette tradition et elle l'a même
probablement accéléré et ceci aussi à
cause de l'expérience de la guerre
froide et de la chute de l'Union
soviétique
on l'a considéré comme la fin de
l'histoire la dissolution de l'URSS en
1991 mais fin à un demi-siècle de
confrontation s ouest déclassée sur la
scène internationale la Russie voit ses
anciennes républiques soviétiques
tournaient leur regard non plus vers
Moscou mais vers l'Ouest et en
particulier vers l'Union européenne et
le temps
malgré la fin du rideau de fer
l'élargissement de l'Alliance atlantique
se poursuit post-guerre froide
des états hier membres du pacte de
Varsovie sont à présent membre de l'OTAN
ces pays sont devenus membres de l'OTAN
mais il faut se souvenir dans quel
contexte ce contexte c'est celui de la
fin de la chute d'Union soviétique et
de pays qui se sentent à la fois pour
qui l'Occident est un modèle même
fantasmé
clairement mais aussi l'OTAN est vu
comme et bien une garantie de sécurité
contre l'ancien colon
et dans ce mouvement l'Ukraine considéré
comme le berceau de la civilisation
russe et met le souhait d'un
rapprochement avec le temps six années
après l'annexion par la Russie de l'une
de ses provinces la Crimée
[Musique]
l'Ukraine représente dès le Dhu de
l'Union soviétique un enjeu important et
on le voit dès 2004 2005 quand l'Ukraine
commence à se tourner vers l'Occident
quand l'Ukraine décide finalement de ce
débarrasser de personnages corrompus
assez liés au Kremlin quand elle se
décide de s'engager dans une voie plus
indépendante et bien la Russie ne l'a
pas accepté
ce nouveau destin voulu par l'Ukraine
est insupportable pour les autorités du
Kremlin dès 2021 la Russie renforce sa
présence militaire aux frontières de
l'Ukraine
la Russie a commencé en 2021 à
intensifier son activité dans une forme
de de dissuasion stratégique qui est une
activité pré-remptive une activité
proactive à la fois non militaire et
militaire indirect donc par la
démonstration de force et donc on l'a vu
avec les exercices massifs et les
déploiements massifs autour de l'Ukraine
en Biélorussie mais pas que
face à ces menaces l'Ukraine ne cède pas
la tension est à son comble et les
mouvements russes toujours constants
trois jours avant l'invasion la Russie
reconnaît l'indépendance de deux zones
séparatistes à l'est de l'Ukraine dans
le don de basse cette escalade aboutit
aux 24 février 2022 jour où la Russie
envahit l'Ukraine
et si la guerre fait rage depuis bientôt
huit mois à présent le conflit n'a pas
débordé les frontières de l'OTAN
il n'a pas eu de débordements militaires
c'est-à-dire que la Russie n'a pas
attaqué des forces de l'OTAN l'OTAN n'a
pas attaqué des forces russes donc on
peut dire c'est honnêtement c'est une
politique assez rationnelle assez
mesurée et donc à ses pertinente et qui
comment dire n'auront pas avec les
engagements de l'Occident n'auront pas
avec la morale qu'il entend défendre et
avec la vision de l'homme et de la
société et du de l'ordre international
qui le défend face à l'agression russe
la réponse collective de l'Alliance et
de taille au total l'OTAN mène huit
missions sur le flanc Est de l'Europe
près de 40 000 militaires des pays
membres de l'Alliance atlantique son
mobilisés et c'est ici à Mons en
Belgique que son pensée est planifié ses
opérations
où est-ce qu'on est ici
bonjour Alors là vous êtes vous êtes à
l'état-major du SHAPE à Mons alors shape
c'est le suprime head quarters Elite
powers your mother c'est le commandement
stratégique opérationnel de l'OTAN en
Europe ici nous sommes en relation non
seulement avec l'Alliance en tant
qu'alliance mais avec chacun des 30 pays
membres de cette alliance donc moi en
tant que représentant militaire de la
France j'ai à la demande ou à mon
initiative une relation directe et
privilégiée avec chacune des 29 autres
représentations militaires notre mission
c'est vraiment de faire la liaison entre
nos nations et l'état-major
et donc on est 30 30 officiers à
représenter nos pays qu'on se qu'on se
rencontre
plusieurs fois par semaine je pense que
c'est bien de se voir comme ça
effectivement il y a des relations
bilatérales qui se passent ici beaucoup
plus vite et plus facile que que en
dehors
allez façon de parler long gris et à 50
m de la Belgique et de la France tandis
que si on doit suivre les chemins
officiels c'est un peu plus loin quoi
au sein de cet état-major les 30 pays
membres de l'Alliance sont représentés
ici à la représentation militaire
française les échanges avec Paris sont
permanents
Mons pour l'OTAN c'est la tête de chêne
du campement des opérations de l'OTAN
l'arpentation militaire française il
porte et sert les positions françaises
elle sert d'échelon de liaison entre
Paris et l'OTAN dans le domaine des
opérations et là précisément ce matin on
vérifie avec Paris qu'on est bien sur le
même tempo sur les mêmes compréhension
des sujets sur les mêmes niveaux de
participation dans le domaine des
opérations et puis ça permet aussi à la
France de répondre au mieux
sollicitations de l'OTAN aux besoins de
l'Alliance
et ça permet aussi de mieux expliquer à
l'alliance quels sont les moyens et les
engagements français
pour nous rejoindre dans le battle group
en Roumanie alors sa tendance à
se multiplier
lors de cette visioconférence avec le
centre de planification et de conduite
des opérations basées à Paris la guerre
en Ukraine et dans tous les esprits la
participation française aux opérations
de l'OTAN une réflexion permanente la
France est une en anglais capable nation
donc elle est attendue sur ses
responsabilités de capable national
d'emmener avec elle d'autres alliés dans
des dispositifs collectifs capables de
mettre à disposition de participer à la
diffusion collective de l'Alliance bref
et de jouer son rôle de grande nation
dans dans la défense collective de
l'Europe
alors la France a toujours été un
partenaire premier et très étroit de
l'Alliance tout d'abord par notre
contribution financière quatrième
contributeur financier au sein de
l'Alliance ensuite par notre
contribution humaine
5e contributeur en termes de ressources
humaines personnelles engagé dans la
différence état-major et puis ensuite je
serais tenté de dire au regard des
engagements opérationnels la France est
engagée sur l'ensemble des théâtres à
côté de ses partenaires de l'Alliance
que ce soit dans les airs en mer ou sur
terre
sur Terre en Roumanie quatre mois après
l'agression russe l'engagement français
se place à présent sous le signe de
l'entraînement interallié ce matin un
exercice de grande ampleur est en cours
baptisé scorpion Legacy il rassemble
2000 militaires de plusieurs
nationalités et se déroule à smartdam à
une quinzaine de kilomètres que la
frontière Ukraine
donc on est sur un exercice majeur
intérieur de l'OTAN et une phase de tir
réel ou toutes les nationalités vont
tirer donc on est loin de 9 nationalités
donc des Français on est là des
Américains des Portugais des Belges des
Roumains des Italiens des Bulgares et
donc là sur les trois jours qui arrivent
le but c'est d'apprendre à travailler
ensemble pour se coordonner donc faut
que tout le monde soit puisse interagir
en même temps et en simultané et ensuite
ça reste sur la mission de base de
l'OTAN et la mission aigle sur laquelle
on est nous qui est la réassurance et la
réassurance passe par montrer nos bras
et nos muscles donc on est là aussi pour
ça puisqu'on est une quinzaine de
kilomètres de la frontière
dans ce scénario l'escadron de Charles
léger français sera au coeur de la mêlée
il aura pour rôle de figer l'ennemi pour
permettre aux autres nations de
transpercer les lignes adverses
une fois qu'on aura fixé l'ennemi et
détruit le premier échelon les Alliés
donc les Polonais les Portugais vont
nous dépasser par la gauche et par la
droite pour ensuite
s'engager plus loin dans le fuseau
l'élément central de cet exercice sera
la coordination car si ces nations sont
engagées sous une même bannière il est
nécessaire d'harmoniser les procédures
et les tactiques
avec différentes nations comme la France
c'est portugais les Bulgares les
Roumains et nous nous entraînons avec
nos procédures la coopération avec les
Français est très bonne pour moi
la communication est très bonne et
niveau des Français est très élevé donc
c'est un plaisir pour moi de m'entraîner
avec eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec 2000 militaires et plus de 150
véhicules engagés la manœuvre qui a duré
plus de deux heures est un succès
c'est important de s'entraîner ensemble
parce que ça nous permet de nous
synchroniser en particulier pour nos
procédures tactiques
[Musique]
on en retient du coup cette fierté
d'être là en premier
avoir été déclenché sur la pour la
première fois sur cette alerte niveau
autant c'est pas rien quand même mais
avec beaucoup de choses à retenir sur le
futur et sur la création de cette armée
otanienne et toi
déclencher fin février 2022 au titre de
nation cadre de la force de réaction
rapide de l'OTAN ces éléments français
ont au fil des mois peaufiné à savoir
faire en coalition
au vu de la situation en Ukraine on n'a
pas changé dispositif mais on a changé
d'appellation c'est à dire que on était
plus le bataillon fer de lance de la
réaction de l'OTAN mais on était on est
devenu comme dans les 8 autres des sept
autres pays frontaliers de la
Biélorussie et de la Russie et l'Ukraine
un bataillon de forwards de présence
avancée pour réassurer les pays
frontaliers et maintenir une présence
dissuasive aux frontières de l'OTAN
alors qu'à terre l'OTAN a renforcé sa
présence tout au long de ses frontières
est en mer à plusieurs mois de conflit
la posture a également évolué
[Musique]
à la Bulgarie se poursuivent
et pour connaître et anticiper toutes
menaces potentielles au-delà des
frontières de l'Alliance la France met à
disposition de l'OTAN des moyens
stratégiques de surveillance et de
détection
comme chaque semaine depuis l'invasion
russe la base aérienne d'Avord l'ancre
des awaks et mobilisé
nous compare en Pologne pour 10h de vol
ça c'est fréquent comme mission on en
fait de nombreuses fois par semaine et
c'est des vols qui sont relativement
intenses parce que justement il y a une
belle amplitude de vol et souvent des
horaires un petit peu décalés et combien
de temps pour préparer l'avion moi il me
faut une heure
de A à Z
alors que ce mécanicien navigant prépare
l'aéronef le chef de mission Brive ses
opérateurs de surveillance et de
contrôle
les objectifs du vol c'est de détecter
et surveiller tout ce qui peut voler
donc à l'est de ce flan oriental
otanien détecté tout ce qui peut être
présence de surface
au niveau des abords et des entrées
maritimes et également et ben mettre à
jour
notre connaissance de la zone avec tous
les éléments qu'ils soient seuls surface
et
un équipage awak s'est constitué d'une
vingtaine de personnes qui orienté
principalement sur la surveillance et là
nous sommes en train de configurer
l'avion un awak c'est les yeux et les
oreilles de l'OTAN donc pour cette
mission avec une vision pouvant aller à
plus de 400 km autour de sa position sur
360 degrés
pendant 10 heures ces opérateurs de
surveillance vont détecter et analyser
au profit de l'OTAN tout mouvement
militaire au-delà de la frontière
polonaise
natation est bien ça va être de détecter
et de surveiller les aéronefs dans les
pays qui nous entourent donc
calligrade l'Ukraine la Biélorussie les
Pays-Bas nous sommes trois opérateurs de
surveillance et donc nous allons nous
séparer différentes zones afin et bien
de mieux analyser chaque aéros
situation
bien pour les comme c'est ras pour le
moment
[Musique]
à bord 9 spécialités sont représentées
les yeux rivés sur l'harmonica chaque
opérateur contribue à obtenir une
cartographie précise de la situation
tactique en temps réel le sergent-chef
Moreno par exemple est spécialiste des
émissions électromagnétiques
ça va être de caractériser les émissions
électromagnétiques donc pour schématiser
on va écouter ce qui se passe aux
alentours de l'avion
radars on va les caractériser on va être
en mesure de les identifier voilà avec
grâce à certains paramètres
[Musique]
et une fois qu'on les a identifié on va
diffuser que potentiellement on sera
face à des menaces comme je vous ai dit
surface des bâtiments des bateaux des
menaces terrestres des systèmes d'armes
et des radars de veille et ainsi que
d'activité aériennes alors notre mission
est de recueillir l'information et de
l'envoyer en tant quasi réel au
commandement hôtelien ainsi que à tout
les analystes qui pourront analyser ces
comportements et établir l'état des
forces russes aux portes de l'Europe
[Musique]
après ce que huit mois du conflit
russo-ukrainien force de constater que
cette confrontation n'a pas débordé les
frontières de l'OTAN
sans être engagé contre la Russie la
France et ses alliés ont su faire preuve
de détermination et de fraternité face
au retour de la guerre aux portes de
l'Europe
par leur présence avancée en Roumanie et
en Estonie par ses engagements en
Méditerranée et dans les cieux de l'Est
de l'Europe les armées françaises ont su
réagir vite et avec force
mais à travers ces déploiements la
France a surtout démontré sa capacité à
tenir son rang et ses responsabilités au
sein de l'Alliance atlantique et
approuvé une fois de plus son
attachement au respect du droit
international
grâce à son modèle d'armée complet la
France n'a pas hésité à monter au front
de la sécurité collective européenne
[Musique]